[Music]
do
here then we see self-consciousness
withdrawn into its innermost being
for which all externality as such has
vanished withdrawn
into the contemplation of the i equals i
in which this i is the whole of
essentiality and existence
it is submerged in this notion of itself
for it has been driven to the limit of
his
extremes and moreover in such a way that
the moments distinguished whereby it is
real
or is still consciousness are not only
for us these pure extremes
on the contrary what it is for itself
and what
is for it intrinsic and what is for
existence have evaporated into
abstractions
which no longer have any stability any
substance for this consciousness itself
and all that before was essential being
for consciousness has reverted into
these abstractions
refined into purity consciousness exists
in its poorest form
and the poverty which constitutes its
sole possession is itself a vanishing
this absolute certainty into which
substance has resolved itself is the
absolute
untruth which collapses internally
it is the absolute self-consciousness in
which consciousness is submerged
if we wanted to be facetious we could
say that paragraph
657 is the absolute
turning point of this morality section
and why do i say that that would be
facetious because hegel uses the term
absolute so many times in here
and yet you know his his philosophy is a
philosophy of the absolute but we don't
see the absolute emerging
as such so quite so often in the course
of the dialectical developments in the
phenomenology
this paragraph is chock-full of it you
might say well what's that about
well he is telling us that we're
reaching a kind of
limit point that the dialectic
the you might say phenomenological
investigation of what is actually going
on
in morality and particularly
in conscience how is that playing itself
out something
raises itself almost like stones coming
out of the soil
the the you know the bedrock that we can
see a great example this is you know
if you've ever been to new hampshire
it's called the granite state
in part because there's so many
formations where the
granite is coming out of the dirt
and you can see the rocks underneath not
so great for farming in many respects
but quite dramatic and here we're
getting to see
you might say the underbelly or the
how things really are how they stand now
this is not
meant to be a one time
solved at for all sort of pessimistic
solution to things so we shouldn't take
it that way
but there is a lot of stuff going on
here and i want to i want to begin
at the end of this and then sort of
trace our way back to the beginning and
come through it
so he talks in the very last sentence
about a bunch of absolutes he says
this absolute certainty into which
substance has resolved itself
is the absolute untruth which collapses
internally it is the absolute
self-consciousness
in which consciousness is submerged so
you notice three absolutes right there
in one single sentence and
there's a lot of equating uh these
absolutes or saying that one of these
is the other is the other and each of
these is providing us
with a different way of looking at
things
now that should bring into
some question the use of this term
absolute none of these absolutes are
actually
absolute because they're all related to
each other
in this way and let's hesitate for a
moment on these different absolutes we
have
absolute certainty this height
right and this this entire section is
about
conscience in so there's a strong
connection there
this absolute certainty is absolute
untruth and notice he doesn't say
an absolute lie he doesn't even say
absolute falsity
right falsite he doesn't say
anything like that instead this is just
a
negative of truth the the lack of truth
and there's a lot of ways in which truth
can be missing as i just mentioned a lie
you know truth is missing in a very set
of determinant ways
we're going to look at you know later on
in this section at hypocrisy
and you could say that's also a form of
untruth that reveals certain truths
that don't map on to other things that
we know to be true right
this is more of a there's isn't truth
there
and that should you know raise our our
our antenna a little bit you you could
say
so we'll come back to that by the end of
this and probably
even more so in the next paragraph he
also talks about absolute
self-consciousness
that's an interesting way to talk isn't
it because
can self-consciousness really be
absolute given that self-consciousness
as we discovered in the
self-consciousness section
and in all the refinements and the
reason and
uh spirit section up to this point
self-consciousness is always
self-consciousness in relation to an
other
and not just an other that is another of
consciousness
but an other self-consciousness
right the other of self-consciousness is
and
other self-consciousness so it can never
truly be
just what it is it can't be a substance
it can't be
something that is purely in itself it
always has to be for
itself and for others so what does it
mean to be absolute
self-consciousness this is where we get
to see that
absolute self-consciousness is really
illusory you can't you can't have it
at this this point and he talks about
consciousness and consciousness by
itself
is always consciousness of something
right
this is phenomenological so the
consciousness of what in this case he
doesn't he doesn't answer that
question he's speaking very abstractly
he tells us that consciousness is
submerged
in this he uses this language of
vanishing
being submerged sinking into
a lot in this section things are
going into other things and thereby
being
you could say lost in the process
can consciousness be entirely absorbed
in
self-consciousness if we do that we we
kind of lose the world
don't we we lose others as well
and so this is a fitting place to return
to
what is being left behind at this point
and this is what he's talking about at
the start of this
he tells us here then we see
self-consciousness
withdrawn into its innermost being so
part of what makes self-consciousness
self-consciousness is the capacity to be
reflexive to take a stand upon itself
right
and we can also say that
self-consciousness
is what can say i of itself and that is
what it's doing here the i
equals right
these are the an identity statement but
it's always vacuous
so self-consciousness returns into its
innermost self which is supposed to be
you know full of richness and substance
and you know we finally attain the whole
point of morality and all the other
stuff
leading up to this and then he says
for this all externality as such
has vanished withdrawn into the
contemplation
of the i equals i so does this mean that
the external world has actually gone
away
or the social world of others their
expectations
and all the dynamics no but there's
there's a he uses this word abstraction
a little bit later on
an abstraction is going on on the part
of self-consciousness it is making of
itself
through its own agency and activities a
thing separated off from from
other things so externality doesn't go
away but externality as such
oyster liquid alzolka goes away
for this brief moment of this this
paragraph
what else has been left behind well
what was talked about in the previous
paragraphs right
if you look at paragraph 655
and 656 we we get this you know
incredibly optimistic point of view
don't we
you know i'll just read a little bit of
the start of 656.
this solitary divine worship is at the
same time
essentially the divine worship of a
community
the pure inner knowing and perceiving of
itself advances to the moment of
consciousness the contemplation of
itself is its objective existence
and this objective element is the
declaration of its knowing
and willing as something universal isn't
that great
and later on he's talking about this
this is a
community gomanda of
self-consciousnesses and it looks like
we have finally gotten to the point
where self-consciousness has attained to
what it's been looking for this entire
time
recognition on air cannon what it was
seeking out
in the early parts of self-consciousness
in the master slave dialectic
in those three forms of consciousness
that that surpassed that stoicism
skepticism
the unhappy consciousness which you
notice hegel is going to talk about in
the next paragraph
all of that is being left behind
sort of like the proverbial ladder
that's discarded once you
have actually climbed up now
this makes it illusory and by it i mean
all of this
the eye that is equal to the eye he goes
on
and he sketches out how this i
this self-consciousness was drawn into
itself figures
itself he says in which this
eye is the whole the the totality
of essentiality vaseline
and existence
right so everything that is or
everything that matters
everything that is determinative is
there in the eye
then he tells us again he uses this this
uh
language of sinking into you know
falling into so he says it is submerged
in this notion
of itself now notion is because
right uh it vanishes or it sinks into
this
notion of itself which seems to be a
good thing
uh so self-consciousness becomes now
a concept or notion of
the self but what does it actually have
hegel goes on and he tells us it has
been driven to the limit of
its extremes and moreover in such a way
that the moments distinguished whereby
it is real or is still consciousness
attached to things you know the the
community the outside
world its duties
he says are not only for us these pure
extremes on the contrary what it is for
itself
and what is for intrinsic and what is
for existence
here's the key point have evaporated
into abstractions
abstractions now what is it to be
abstract
he said well it means to be an idea in
somebody's head
yeah some ideas are abstract and some
ideas aren't you know
my idea of the children that i will talk
to later tonight is not really an
abstract idea my idea of children
per se could be an abstraction right
so ideas can be more or less abstract as
well we we should keep in mind it's not
as if there's like
ideas that are abstract and then
whatever we're going to oppose to the
abstract the concrete the particular the
specific
the real no it's more of a gradation and
some ideas can be so abstract
as to become almost like mere sounds
that sound cool that we have some sort
of emotional attachment to
and don't have any real content
then they're not concepts in that case
so what does hegel say here these are
pure abstractions
and he tells us these no longer have any
stability
no halt right no substance use the word
substance there
for this consciousness itself if they
don't have any for
this consciousness itself they don't
have it for anybody because these are
this consciousness's ideas that it's
working with
and then he goes on and he says all that
was before essential being for
consciousness has reverted
into these abstractions that's really
important
everything that was essential being is
now abstractions
and this is a form of poverty he talks
about this
refined into this purity consciousness
exists in its pure
poorest form the poverty which
constitutes its soul
possession is itself a vanishing
what are these these sorts of uh things
well you know
anything that would tell us about the
self and about the thing that you know
we've been wanting to know about this
entire
its duties and actions and whether it's
good or bad or any of that
it's all become abstractions at this
point so
why use this word untruth that's a good
way of describing abstractions
they're not actually false they don't
refer to anything in this case right
so and they they kind of cohere with
each other but in a way that doesn't
mean a damn thing
so where are we going to go from here
well this this is as i mentioned
a turning point
looking at this submergence of
consciousness within itself we see that
the
unexplicated substance is for
consciousness knowledge
as its knowledge as consciousness it is
divided into the antithesis of itself
and its object which is for its essence
but it is just this object that is
perfectly transparent is its own self
and its consciousness is only this
knowledge of itself
all life all spiritual essentiality has
withdrawn into this self
and has lost its difference from the eye
itself
the moments of consciousness are
therefore these extreme extract
abstractions none of which endures but
each of which loses itself in the other
and produces it
it is the fluctuating attitude to itself
of the unhappy consciousness
but here this fluctuation takes place
explicitly for consciousness
within itself and is conscious of being
the
notion of reason whereas the unhappy
consciousness is only
implicitly that notion the absolute
certainty of itself thus finds itself
consciousness changed immediately into a
sound that dies away
into an objectification of its being for
self
but this created world is its speech
which likewise
it has immediately heard and only the
echo of what which returns to it
this return therefore does not mean that
the self is in essence in actuality
present
in its speech for essence is not for it
and in itself
or merely implicit being but its very
self
just as little has consciousness and
outer existence for the
objective aspect does not get as far as
being a negative of the
actual self in the same way that this
self does not attain to an actual
existence it lacks the power to
externalize itself
the power to make itself into a thing
and to endure
mere being it lives in dread of
besmirching the splendor of its inner
being by action
and in existence and in order to
preserve the purity of its heart it
flees from contact with the actual
world and persists in its self-willed
impotence to renounce itself which is
reduced to the extreme
of ultimate extract abstraction and to
give itself
a substantial existence or to transform
its thought into being
and put its trust in the absolute
difference between thought and being
the hollow object which it has produced
for itself now fills it therefore with a
sense of emptiness its
activity is a yearning which merely
loses itself as consciousness becomes an
object of void of substance and rising
above this loss and falling back on
itself finds itself only as a lost
soul in this transparent purity of its
moments an unhappy
so-called beautiful soul its light
dies away within it and it vanishes like
a shapeless vapor
that dissolves into thin air
paragraph 658 is a long one and there's
a lot going
on in there including a reference back
to previous sections of the
phenomenology
hegel's also bringing up this this uh
figure or gestalt we could say the shape
of consciousness
that is called the beautiful soul the
zela and this is quite important he's
giving us
an analysis here of it and it's not just
a conceptual analysis it's also one in
terms of
affectivity as well
and so this is one of the
traps that morality can fall
into and you know this has drawn a lot
of attention from commentators and
interpreters not least because hegel
actually gives you a nice phrase here
the beautiful soul to hang things on but
because people see this happening
in era after era after era it's not
something
you could say peculiar to the dialectic
as hegel is laying it out this is
something that a lot of people who
don't buy into hegel's larger project
have drawn
out of it and i think there's there's
really something here
worth identifying but we also want to
locate it within
this process as it's going on within the
phenomenology we don't want it to become
ironically just yet another abstraction
right so um let's take a look at what's
actually going on here
so in the previous paragraph we have
this this turning point
where because the acting
subject is not actually acting it was
withdrawing into themselves into pure
self-knowing
and pure conscience and pure
consciousness as self-consciousness
we see everything becomes abstractions
and
it's really you know sort of like sand
falling through its hands you could say
so he says looking at this submergence
of consciousness within
itself what is the submergence well you
know pure self-consciousness would
involve
a going under a submergence a
sinking into on the part of
consciousness of the world of others
of things and and then we have pure
self-consciousness
just sort of naval gazing you might
almost say
so he says that looking at this
emergence we
see that the unexplicated substance is
for consciousness knowledge as
not as knowledge but as its knowledge as
the knowledge that it has
and so he says as consciousness it's
divided into
this antithesis of itself and its object
which
is for it essence and so antithesis here
is gegenzotz we could just say
opposition if you want to it doesn't
have to be necessarily
antithesis and the gegen zotz is
important because it's between
the thing itself or rather
not a thing consciousness and it's
gagenstand the thing that is over
against it right so the gegenzotz is
sort of putting something over there and
now there's
there's me and my my object
and so we have this itself
and object and both of these are
within consciousness he says um
an object which is for an essence it is
just this object that is perfectly
transparent
it's not like other objects where
there's sort of a resistance
an object which is its own self and
its consciousness is only this knowledge
of itself
okay so it's not really an object
standing over against me as a thing or
even as an
other right another self-consciousness
it's just me
me standing against myself this is part
of why he's going to bring up the unh
happy consciousness a little bit later
when i think
you know looking at this is we could
criticize hegel and say why are you
bringing up the unhappy consciousness at
this point
what's going on here is much more
similar to what's happening
in the reason section or even maybe in
the stoicism and skepticism
uh part of self-consciousness or you
know
some other things right so we'll talk
about that in a moment
let's let's follow this out the
knowledge that it has the vision
is really only of itself so we're not
getting out of this problem
of abstractions that don't seem to
really mean anything
although they sound awfully nice and he
goes on and he says
all life all spiritual essentiality has
withdrawn into the self
and lost its difference from the eye
itself
now there's there's an achievement here
right all life
all spiritual essentiality is no longer
outside of me it's in me
but does that do me any good well let's
go on and see the moments of
consciousness he says are these extreme
abstractions none of which endures but
each of which loses itself in the other
and produces itself
so this is a fluctuating attitude is how
how
miller is translated vexil you know an
interplay back and forth
uh it is a fluctuating attitude to
itself
of the unhappy consciousness but here
the fluctuation takes place explicitly
for consciousness within itself how is
this different than the unhappy
consciousness
little reminder the unhappy
consciousness
which is a dialectic and
a shape of consciousness coming after
the you know self-consciousness origin
struggle to the death master slave
dialectic stoicism
skepticism unhappy consciousness long
section
basically about humankind's religious
attitudes
which consist in a projection
of what is essential out there onto
a divine other something that's going to
be eternal something that's going to
matter
and we then become the unessential
worshipers or objects of salvation
petitioners whatever it's going to be
there's lots of different
uh particular content that can go into
this and he goes through that
you can go back to the unhappy
consciousness section and check that out
so in that case there's this projection
outside of ourselves of something that
isn't really outside of ourselves
but we forget that we're doing the
projection as a matter of fact it
becomes part of our
society part of our social dynamic that
we think that there is
a absolute lord or pantheon or whatever
it's going to be right
so in this case we don't have that
taking place because it's in us
we know we're not projecting projecting
something outside of ourselves it's all
getting projected
inside now the question is is there
enough
inside in there for all of this to be
sustained
and the answer is no there isn't um
it it requires in a certain respect so
i'm going to say something that goes
outside the text here but kind of leads
us to where we're going later on
if the problem of the unhappy
consciousness is projecting
on the part of an essential
consciousness it's essentiality outside
of itself
onto some others and also not being
happy with other human
others except maybe intercessors as that
essential other the problem here
is in some respects the opposite the
others outside of ourselves are also
essential they are other
self-consciousnesses
and we thought we could like bring it
all into ourselves
and make ourselves the locust point for
for meaning and this is part of what the
enlightenment itself is oriented towards
um and you know we can see this in
more speculative frameworks we can see
this in very practical frameworks
that's the what the limit that's being
reached here so he goes on and he says
that this this consciousness is
conscious of being the notion of
reason the grief uh definitely right
um whereas the unhappy consciousness is
only implicitly
that notion and you remember the the
unhappy consciousness
terminates and then leads into that
entire
reason section so this is realizing
what was going on in the reason section
remember too where did reason end up
in practical reason giving laws to
itself and then some some you know
problems
on that respect that had to lead us then
to spirit to the community
right so we've got all this stuff going
on here
and then we've got this transformation
moving to the notion of reason
now he talks about a kind of talking or
speech he says
the absolute certainty of itself finds
itself as
consciousness changed immediately into a
sound that dies
away a sound
now we're not yet at speech but
it's making some sort of sound into an
objective
objectification of its being for self
now he talks about it as being speech
this created
world jaffa novelt this
world that we're creating through our
knowing through our
potential agency acting is its speech
veda it's talking it's discourse which
likewise that he has immediately heard
and only the echo of which returns to it
now he goes on with this metaphor and he
says this return does not mean the self
is in essence
an actuality present in its speech
essence is not for it and in itself or
merely implicit being but it's very
self now what's the problem here i mean
this sounds pretty great right it's
bringing in the dimension of language
isn't that involvement with the other
sure you know we can go on further he
doesn't do that here though he says
just as little has consciousness and
outer existence
the objective aspect does not get as far
as being a negative of the actual self
in the same way this self does not
attain to an actual existence
the self at this point with all of this
you know really interesting
development can't sustain itself it's
reliant on something else
to sustain it and
it's not affecting the world which
continues to exist
outside of it that it hasn't attained a
relation to at this point
so he says it lacks the power to
externalize itself
it lacks this power to make itself
something
other some dynamic that we've seen in
all the discussion about duty and action
right
it always involves an externalization a
subjecting of oneself and one's action
and intentions and
you know fulfillment of duty and plans
and all that to
a world which is to some degree outside
of our control
and which will reinterpret our action
and which we
are connected to and can't get away from
this self is trying to get away from
that and thereby
doesn't externalize itself it lacks the
power to make itself into a thing
and to endure mere being to endure your
being what does that mean
that means being willing to have other
people tell you what the meaning of your
action is
many people can't handle that they need
to tell everybody else what is really
going on
but a mature relationship to reality
is not just a mature relationship to
external things it's a mature
relationship to others and being willing
to handle them telling you you're a jerk
your your motives are actually not as
good as you make them out to be
and be able to endure that right
so he goes on and he's got this
wonderful phrase here
it lives in dread of besmirching
the splendor of its inner being by
action and
in existence now dread anxiety is
another way of translating this
angst it lives in angst
the angst is of acting
and thereby what
besmirching how does this merging take
place
could be that i've got all these great
ideas of who i am in my head
and when i go try to go to do them it's
just a mess
like when i try to go to draw right i
can picture things in my head
i remember as a kid uh you know being on
on this this used to be my family farm
it was bought by this lawyer
who put a bunch of goats there and i
remember seeing a goat on a picnic table
and like almost taking a photograph of
that in my mind thinking i'm gonna draw
that later on
and i had exactly what i wanted it to
look like
in my mind and then i go to use my
clumsy hands that are not very well
trained and it came out looking like
crap right so maybe our actions are like
that the best merchant takes place that
way
or maybe we act and then somebody else
comes along
and says as we've seen in the previous
dialectics oh your motives are not is
pure your intention is not what you
claim it to be you're just trying to
make a buck you're trying to
you know get followers you're trying to
be a big shot
you're doing you know you're trying to
do this to show somebody else up
it's possible for it to be besmirched in
many ways and one way you can make sure
that it's not besmirched
don't do anything if you're afraid of
your actions
being not exactly what you want not
having the splendor
the hairley kite you being the master
right
of the inner being of what it is that
you intend not being the hero of your
own story well
just don't do anything just you know put
it on twitter or
instagram about you know all the
wonderful
things that you're intending to do all
the causes you endorse
but don't actually do anything so he
goes on and
well what else by action and an
existence
right by actually existing as opposed to
mere being
it doesn't match up entirely and that's
that's the wage of existence i mean
here hegel actually sounds like a
hardcore existentialist doesn't he yeah
so those who are like oh you know the
existentialists are totally against
hegel
uh this is a great point of intellectual
history where you want to say oh well
maybe not so much
right maybe they actually drew upon some
aspects of this
he goes on and he says in order to
preserve the purity of its heart it
flees from contact with the actual world
persists in its self-willed impotence to
renounce itself
which it reduced to the extreme of
ultimate abstraction and to give itself
a substantial existence or to transform
its thought into being and put its trust
in the absolute difference between
thought and being
it renounces that it renounces let's go
back to this
transforming its thought into being and
putting its
trust in the absolute difference between
thought and being this is the core
of what hegel's philosophy is about you
you don't have ideas unless you actually
put those ideas into existence
into action and then they never turn out
to be exactly what you intended them to
be there's always a
gagging zone there or perhaps even
fuller types of antithesis
and that's the way that's the way it
works that's what you get if you want to
say oh no i want it to be better than
that
you're you're engaging in a kind of
idealism that is not hegelian idealism
he is making fun of this idealism here
so he goes on and he says now this is
where it gets really interesting in my
view
it talks about a hollow object right
uh hola gegenstad that is this object it
it's hollow
and the hollowness is that there's
nothing to really stand against it you
don't all you've got are abstractions
right
the hollow object which it has produced
for itself now
fills it with a sense or more
specifically
consciousness of emptiness layer height
bovustein a sense of
emptiness and he says it it does engage
in activity the beautiful soul its
activity is a yearning
which merely loses itself as
consciousness becomes an
object a void of substance and rising
above this loss falling back on itself
finds itself and now here miller says
only as a lost soul
he doesn't actually say a lost soul he
says finds itself only as lost for
lordness right
so there's an interesting thing there
it's finding it's losing
it's finding that it's lost right
what is it it finding it it's a
beautiful soul but the beauty exists
only in being detached from any sort of
activity
if it does engage in real activity uh
real twin in this case then it's not
merely
yearning and this emptiness it becomes
something real and then it's no longer
as beautiful
because any any beautiful action any
morally beautiful action
can always be looked at as not entirely
what it is and is also
ugly so he goes on and he says in the
transparent
purity of its moments an unhappy
so-called
beautiful soul right its light dies away
within it and it vanishes like a
shapeless vapor
that dissolves into thin air there's
there's nothing really
here and even the beauty of the
beautiful soul
can't remain beautiful and it would have
to be translated into something
more substantive something real
you